RONALD SMITH: Well, when I
lectured last on
Wednesday of last week, we went
through a long PowerPoint
presentation about water
in the atmosphere.
And there's a lot of information
in that.
And of course, that lecture's
been posted.
But today we're going to
continue on from there.
We're not finished with water
in the atmosphere.
We're going to move more
towards the subject of
precipitation--
how precipitation forms.
And let me begin by just
describing what you see when
you look at a cloud.
So I've got a little
cartoon here.
I'm going to make a cloud
in just a minute.
But what do you see when
you look at a cloud?
There's a cloud.
There's you as the observer.
You are-- when you look away
from the cloud, you're seeing
sunlight that has scattered
off air molecules.
And that light looks
blue to you.
When you look at the cloud
itself, you see sunlight that
is scattered off tiny condensed
water droplets.
And that cloud looks
white to you.
Under certain circumstances,
if you look at the rain
falling from the cloud and the
light, the orientation of the
illumination is just right,
you'll see a rainbow.
So what's going on?
Why do you see three such very
different things when you look
at a cloud?
Well, it has to do with the
different types of the way
light scatters from particles.
And so I wanted to just run
through this before we got any
further into clouds.
If you imagine a photon of
light with a certain
wavelength lambda approaching
a particle, it's going to be
scattered off by that particle
in some direction.
What matters is the ratio of the
wavelength of the light to
the diameter of the droplet,
that ratio.
If the wavelength is much, much
larger than the diameter
of the droplet, that's called
Rayleigh scattering, named
after the famous English
physicist. And under that
condition, the scattering, you
say S, is proportional to one
over the wavelength to
the fourth power.
In other words, the shorter the
wavelength, the more is
the scattering under
that condition.
The shorter the wavelength for
the same particle, the more is
the scattering.
Well, that's why the sky is
blue because the visible
spectrum includes red on the
long wave side, green in the
middle, blue on the
short wave side.
So when light comes from the sun
and encounters these small
air molecules, the blue light
is scattered more than the
green and the red.
And therefore, the light
scattered to your eye--
what you saw this morning as you
walked up, the blue sky.
That's because that scattering
is from very small molecules
which places you into the
Rayleigh scattering regime,
where short wavelengths scatter
more intensely than
the longer wavelengths.
So that's why this
sky is blue.
Now the cloud particles
in the cloud are
much larger than molecules.
They're typically 10 microns
in size, which is of such a
wavelength that it puts you
into the so-called Mie
scattering regime where
wavelength is within one or
two orders of magnitude
of the diameter.
It doesn't have to be close to
the same as the diameter but
within a factor of 10
or 100 of the--
I see you straining
to see them.
Let me pull this down,
might help with it.
Mie scattering, if you're in
that regime, all wavelengths
are scattered roughly equally.
Red, green, blue light are
scattered equally.
That is whatever color you have
illuminating the object,
that's the same color
you will get
reflecting from the object.
So if you're illuminating the
object with white light, then
the scattered light will be
white as well, have the same
mix of the different colors
in the spectrum.
So the cloud appears white
to your eye because it's
scattering all those different
solar wavelengths equally.
The other case-- the third case
is when the diameter of
the object is much larger than
the wavelength of light.
That would apply, by the way,
for a raindrop which has a
diameter of about
one millimeter.
And remember the wavelength
we're talking about, for
example, visible light,
is only 0.5 microns.
So that would easily
satisfy that.
And that's the case where
you can trace--
it's called geometric optics is
the physical name for that
scattering regime.
That means you can actually
trace a ray of light that
comes into the raindrop,
refracts as it enters, bounces
off one side, refracts again,
and comes back to your eye
splitting the color slightly
because refractive index-- the
bending of the light is a
function of wavelength,
therefore, giving you this
special rainbow effect.
You couldn't get that
from cloud droplets
because they're too small.
But the fact that they're larger
allows you to see that
splitting of the light and the
rainbow forming in that way.
So that is basically what you
see when you look at a cloud,
and the sky, and
the raindrops.
A couple of other
points though.
There's another way that
meteorologists look at clouds,
and that's with radar--
meteorological radar.
I've sketched that here.
You've got a dish antenna.
You make a microwave signal.
Usually that wavelength
is about 10
centimeters, about like that.
You send it towards the cloud.
And it may or may not scatter
back to your radar system.
If it does, you can determine
the distance from the time it
takes the radar signal to
get there and back.
And you can learn something
about the
particles in that cloud.
But remember, with a longer
wavelength, the same cloud
droplets, and even the
raindrops, are going to be in
the Rayleigh scattering
regime.
So with this longer wavelength,
you're almost
always going to be in the
Rayleigh scattering regime
because your wavelength here
is so much larger than the
wavelength of visible light.
So with that strong inverse
dependence on wavelength, and
the diameter comes in too, it
turns out that cloud droplets
do not scatter radar
effectively, but raindrops do.
So when you're looking at a
radar image of a cloud, you
are seeing only where
it is raining.
You do not see the cloud you
see with the visible eye.
With the visible eye, you see
this white puffy thing full of
cloud droplets.
Radar doesn't see that.
Radar goes right through.
But the radar will bounce off
from the raindrops or the
snowflakes within that cloud.
So remember when using a
meteorological radar, you are
seeing precipitation rather
than clouds per se.
Of course, clouds produced
precipitation, but they are
different things.
Any questions on that?
OK.
Well, that is background.
We can do a little experiment
to make a cloud.
I've got a vacuum pump hidden
under here and a little grey
chamber that I'm going
to evacuate.
I'm going to hook this up
to the jar in this way.
And then by twisting a valve,
I'm going to allow some of the
air from this jug to pass into
this evacuated cylinder.
When I do that, let's say for
the sake of argument that I
take about that much of the
air from here on up and
suddenly remove it.
Well, then the rest of the air
in the jug is going to expand
to fill the jug.
Now what happens when air
expands suddenly?
We've been over and over this,
but now you're going to see it
in this new context.
When air expands, it does
work on its environment.
And it adiabatically cools.
Its temperature drops
because of that work
it's done in expansion.
When the temperature drops, the
saturation vapor pressure
drops as well.
That is the amount of water
vapor that can be held in the
vapor state suddenly
decreases.
Well, if Ive got-- if this is
the saturation vapor pressure,
and this is the amount of water
vapor that I actually
have, the partial pressure of
water vapor, and I suddenly
drop the temperature, that's
going to drop this value down.
I haven't changed the amount of
water in the air, but I've
decreased the amount that can
be held in the vapor state.
And if I move it down to this
level and slightly beyond,
that excess must suddenly
condense.
It cannot remain in
the vapor state.
And therefore, I'm going to
force a cloud to form in very
much the same way that
the atmosphere does,
by adiabatic expansion.
The only difference is instead
of getting the adiabatic
expansion by lifting a parcel
up into the atmosphere, I'm
doing it with this little
apparatus of suddenly dropping
the pressure.
Are there questions on this?
Now I'm going to give it a few
condensation nuclei because I
prefer to form a large number of
small droplets rather than
a small number of
large droplets.
It'll make the cloud more
visible that way.
So I'm just going to blow a
little bit of smoke in there.
You won't be able to see this,
but these will be very tiny--
these will be very tiny aerosol
particles just to give
the water something
to condense on to.
What you hear is
a vacuum pump.
I have a little gauge here to
tell me whether or not it's
working, whether this chamber
is being evacuated.
I put it on this overhead
projector to get nice
illumination of the chamber.
And you see it's empty now.
There's nothing there.
OK, I think we have a little
bit of a vacuum in here.
So I'm going to try
suddenly opening--
right now this valve
is closed.
So there's low pressure
here but normal--
look--
normal atmospheric pressure
in the jar.
But when I open that valve, some
of the air is going to be
sucked off.
And we'll see this doesn't
always work.
But we'll see if we can form
a cloud this morning.
Three, two, one, there's
a cloud.
Now this is a reversible process
where I suddenly to
bring that parcel back down to
the atmosphere or here just
let the pressure build up,
it would compress warm
and remove the cloud.
So on the count of three, I'm
just going to rip the top out
of there and let atmospheric
pressure push that down again.
Three, two, one.
I'm going to repeat
that again.
Let me close this off.
Let me take questions
for a minute about
what I've done here.
Are there any questions about
what I'm actually doing
physically up here?
Question?
STUDENT: Can you explain
it again?
PROFESSOR: So I'm evacuating
this grey cylinder.
It's just a little reservoir
of low pressure.
When I open the valve, then
some of this atmospheric
pressure is going to bleed off
into here allowing the rest of
the air to expand suddenly.
That's just what happens when an
air parcel rises up in the
atmosphere and expands, cools
adiabatically, drops the
saturation vapor pressure, and
the excess water vapor must
then immediately condense.
And it's finding one of the
small particles in there,
condensation nuclei,
to condense on.
Notice how small these
particles are.
You may have seen them
swirling around.
But they didn't fall out.
Let's watch that the next time
I do the experiment here.
I think we're set.
I haven't got a very
good vacuum.
Maybe this wasn't
closed properly.
It's OK.
Three, two, one.
Now there are tiny particles
in there, but you don't see
them falling.
Sometimes you see them swirling
around a little bit.
There's some air currents
in there.
But they're so small that they
don't really fall out
gravitationally.
I'll reverse the process now.
Three, two, one.
And it's gone.
OK.
That is how a cloud forms. Are
there questions on that?
They're must be some mysteries
on what I've done here.
Anything at all?
STUDENT: Does the jar feel
cold to the touch?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
STUDENT: Does the jar feel
cold to the touch?
PROFESSOR: No.
I don't think the temperature
drop is enough.
And the mass of the jar itself
is too large, I think, for
that to be detectable,
at least by
my hand on the outside.
If we had a proper sensor in
there, we could probably
measure, if it was a fast
response instrument, we could
probably measure a several
degree drop.
I'm guessing--
I haven't done the
calculation.
I'm guessing it would be three
or four degrees Celsius.
I've got a little bit of
liquid water in here.
So this air is pretty
humid to start with.
Probably--
I'm guessing the air in there
is probably 90% or 95%
relative humidity, so I don't
have to cool it too much to
bring it to saturation.
But I doubt that
I can feel that
temperature difference there.
But there is one, but I think
it would have to have a good
sensor inside to feel that.
That's a good question though.
Temperature is a key here, and
that part we can't see.
We could only see the response
of the water vapor to that
drop in temperature.
Yes?
STUDENT: Why do the particles
start swirling after
you have the cloud?
PROFESSOR: Well, when I suck
the air out of
there, remember if I suck it
out, it's not going to come
out smoothly.
It's going to come out suddenly
in one region more
than another.
And that's going to produce
some eddies in there just
because I've suddenly
drawn air out of
one part of the chamber.
So that's just leftover from--
it could also be a little bit
because I'm heating it
from the bottom.
It could be a little bit
of thermal convection.
But I suspect it's mostly just
because I drew the air out
very suddenly from one location
in the bottle.
Anything else on that?
Yes?
STUDENT: For the equation S
approximately 1 over lamda to
the fourth, is that for all the
scattering or just for the
Rayleigh scattering?
PROFESSOR: That's just for
Rayleigh scattering.
Yes.
In fact, for Mie scattering,
you would write S is
approximately independent
of wavelength.
And for geometric optics, it's
more complicated because the
ray is actually bouncing around
inside the raindrop and
scattering in a different way.
So that applies only to the
Rayleigh scattering.
That's the property of-- that
is why the sky is blue when
you scatter off very
small particles.
OK.
Anything else on
the experiment?
Now the subject that we have to
deal with today is how you
take a cloud that is composed of
these tiny cloud droplets,
10 microns in size, too small
to fall gravitationally and
occasionally get rain
out of these clouds.
As I mentioned last time, if you
compare the diameter of a
droplet to the diameter of a
raindrop, there's a factor of
100 difference.
Their volumes are different
by a factor of a million.
That's 100 cubed, because the
volume of the sphere goes like
the cube of the radius.
So we'd have to bring together
a million cloud droplets to
form one raindrop.
How and under what
circumstances are
we going to do this?
There are two theories.
Your book is good in this.
There are two outstanding
theories for this.
The first one is called
collision-coalescence.
If you have tiny cloud droplets,
but they're not all
the same size, some are a little
bit larger than others,
they're not falling very fast.
But the large one is going to be
falling a little bit faster
than the smaller ones.
And therefore, up in the cloud,
the larger ones are
going to overtake the
smaller ones.
And when they collide,
they may coalesce.
They might not.
They might bounce
off each other.
But with some degree of
efficiency, they will coalesce
and make a larger droplet.
Well, now it's going to
fall even faster.
And so it's going to sweep
up smaller droplets at an
increasing rate.
And before you know it, you
could sweep up a million
droplets and form a raindrop.
You may have seen something like
this on a cold winter day
with droplets condensing inside
of your window at home.
Sometimes a drop will start
to move down the window.
And then as it collects up other
droplets, suddenly it
will fall right to the
bottom of the window.
That's kind of what I'm
talking about with
collision-coalescence.
It's not a very efficient
process most of the time,
because these cloud droplets are
too similar to each other.
There's not enough of a range of
large to small particles to
get this going.
But on occasion, especially
over tropical oceans, this
mechanism is thought
to dominate.
The other mechanism, a little
more complicated, so follow
this argument closely.
It assumes that you have
supercooled water droplets,
tiny droplets at a temperature
colder than
zero degrees Celsius.
It wants to freeze.
It's cold enough to freeze.
But it needs something to
trigger the freezing.
That's called a freezing
nucleus.
Some little particle of dust
or some little speck of
something or other that
would trigger
one of those to freeze.
So imagine you've got a cloud
with supercooled liquid water.
And something makes
one of those
droplets suddenly freeze.
So I've drawn it now with a
six-sided shape indicating
it's a ice crystal.
It turns out, here's the key,
that ice at the same
temperature as liquid water
has a slightly lower
saturation vapor pressure.
Ice and water at the same
temperature, the ice has a
slightly lower saturation
water vapor pressure.
That means that the ice is a
little more attractive to
water vapor than
the liquid is.
So I freeze one of
these droplets.
And immediately, it starts
to draw water vapor
towards it and grow.
Meanwhile, the other droplets
begin to shrink because the
humidity is decreasing around,
which starts to evaporate the
cloud droplets that remain.
So before long, this thing has
grown to be quite large
through a vapor deposition
process, initially at least, a
vapor deposition process.
This is a snowflake.
And now it's large.
It will begin to fall out of
the sky and may reach the
ground as a snowflake if the
temperature is warm enough.
It may do other things.
Once it starts to fall,
it may start to hit.
It may kind of go back
to this mechanism.
You might start to
hit some of these
supercooled liquid droplets.
And they will freeze
on impact.
In which case, this will grow
further by riming, by having
supercooled droplets
hit, and stick, and
freeze when they hit.
Eventually, that could lead, for
example, to a hail stone,
where you first form
a snowflake.
And then as it falls out, you
would collect by riming more
of these supercooled
water droplets.
That would eventually produce
a hail stone.
Any questions on this
ice phase mechanism?
This is believed to be the
most common mechanism for
producing rain and snow
around the world.
In fact, the rain we had over
the weekend was almost
certainly of this type.
So most of the rain you've
experienced unless spent over
the tropical oceans
has probably been
formed in this way.
Question?
Yes?
STUDENT: Why does the lower
saturation vapor pressure mean
it attracts more water?
PROFESSOR: So if you remember
the definition of
saturation vapor pressure, if
I have a chamber with a
condensed phase there and the
vapor up here, saturation
vapor pressure is a vapor
pressure that will exist here
when you're in equilibrium
with the condensed vapor.
So if I suddenly change this
from water to say ice, the ice
is more attractive to the vapor
and will suck a little
bit of that extra water vapor
out dropping this until the
new equilibrium is reached.
So I haven't given you a say
quantum mechanical explanation
for why the vapor pressure
over ice is lower.
But I've explained
what that means.
I think that's the best I
can do at this stage.
This is a trickier mechanism.
So I'd be happy to take
questions on this if I haven't
made this clear.
It's called the ice phase
mechanism for
generating rain and snow.
Sometimes it's called the
Bergeron mechanism after the
Norwegian scientist that
developed the idea.
OK, now with that, then let's
talk about some different rain
scenarios-- rain or
snow scenarios.
If you have a shallow cloud,
it's warm at the surface.
And you know somehow from
a balloon sounding or an
aircraft pattern that the top
of that cloud is below the
freezing level.
That is the temperature is
greater than zero degrees
Celsius below, less above,
but the cloud never
reaches that height.
And it's raining.
A simple process of elimination
tells you that
this must be the mechanism.
It must be the
collision-coalescence
mechanism, because there's
no supercooled
liquid water in this.
All the liquid water in the
cloud is at a temperature
above zero degrees Celsius.
So this mechanism is excluded.
It must be a warm
rain mechanism.
Let's go on to the next phase.
Let's say this cloud
is taller now.
And the zero degrees Celsius
line is there, meaning it's
colder above and warmer below.
There's a good section of this
cloud then that will have
supercooled liquid
water in it.
Probably what's happening, if
it's raining out the bottom of
this cloud, it's probably
because the ice phase
mechanism is working, producing
snowflakes up here.
I've drawn my crude
little snowflake.
I made the cardinal sin of
making it a five-pointed star
when ice always has a
six-fold symmetry.
So I hope you can do
better than that.
You should put a Star
of David there.
That would at least have
a six-fold symmetry.
So snow is being produced
via this mechanism.
Then it's falling out.
As soon as it falls and reaches
the zero degrees
Celsius line, it is going to
melt and become a raindrop.
And then it'll fall as rain
all the way to the ground.
So again, the rain we had this
weekend was almost certainly
of that type formed as snow
higher in the atmosphere.
And as it fell, it melted
and became a raindrop.
And we felt it as rain.
That's the most common situation
of all, by the way.
This is extremely common, at
least here in New Haven.
In the winter time, if you had
temperatures less than zero
degrees Celsius everywhere, if
it was cold at the surface,
and of course, even colder aloft
in the troposphere, you
could have the ice phase process
forming snowflakes.
And then they would simply fall
all the way to the ground
as a snowflake.
That's fine.
Occasionally, you may have
encountered situations, or you
will this winter if you keep
your eyes open, where the
temperature at the surface is
almost exactly zero Celsius,
within two or three degrees
of zero Celsius.
So that melting level is right
about at the surface.
What you'll find then is that
the snow that's falling is wet
and sticky.
Because it's actually begun its
melting process in just
the last few seconds as
it's fallen to Earth.
But that'd be the special case
somewhere just between these
two where the zero line-- zero
degrees Celsius is just about
at the surface of the Earth.
Questions on these
scenarios so far?
OK.
Now here's one that's a little
less common but can be quite
important when it happens.
It's called an ice storm.
And you have to imagine a
temperature profile like I've
drawn here.
The vertical line for reference
is the zero degrees
Celsius line.
So there's a zero line aloft but
another zero line close to
the surface.
In other words, cold,
warm, and cold
again near the surface.
So what's going to happen?
Well, up here it's going to
be just like this one.
You're going to have the ice
phase mechanism producing
snowflakes.
They're going to
melt and become
raindrops below that line.
Now they are falling to Earth as
a raindrop, a liquid drop.
But then in the last few hundred
meters before they hit
the surface, they enter
a cold layer of air.
That air is going to cool down
the droplet, probably even
below the freezing mark.
If that air temperature is say
minus five Celsius, then it's
going to cool down that droplet
to about that same
temperature, minus
five Celsius.
So now what do you have?
The first time I mention
this, but you now have
a supercooled raindrop.
Before I was talking about
supercooled cloud droplets.
Now I'm talking about a
supercooled raindrop.
It's a millimeter in size.
But it's supercooled.
That is going to freeze
upon impact and coat
everything with ice.
The power lines are going to be
drooping with the weight.
The branches on the trees are
going to be leaning and
breaking over the weight of that
ice freezing on impact as
those supercooled raindrops
hit the--
STUDENT: So they're raindrops?
PROFESSOR: Supercooled
raindrops.
Right.
This is called freezing
rain or an ice storm.
And the damage is caused
normally--
well, of course, the roads are
going to be dangerous too
because the roads
would be icy.
But most of the damage is going
to come, I think, from
the weight of this on trees,
and power lines, and so on,
occasionally breaking
them, making
them come to the surface.
But for that, you need this
special behavior of the air
temperature.
Which around New England, you
typically get once or twice
each winter, you'll get an ice
storm that has this particular
behavior to it.
Any questions on that?
Well, I can probably
then say a few
words about cloud seeding.
Cloud seeding is an attempt
to get clouds that are not
raining to rain.
You can imagine the frustration
of a farmer who
finds his crops withering
for lack of rain.
And yet all these clouds are
passing by overhead with lots
of condensed water.
But it's all in the cloud
droplet form.
Raindrops are not forming.
He would give anything if he
could just get this process--
one of these two processes
to work, the
collision-coalescence or
the ice phase process.
If the cloud has supercooled
water, he might have a chance.
And this is the way you do it.
You inject into the cloud
some freezing nuclei.
You want to get a few of these
droplets to freeze.
And a good freezing nuclei would
be a compound called
silver iodide.
AgI is the chemical
formula for it.
Because it has a crystal
structure very much
like that of ice.
And so if a particle of silver
iodide hits a supercooled
cloud droplet, it is likely
to cause it to freeze.
And then this process
could start.
So there is a big industry
today in cloud
seeding of cold clouds.
I don't know if I forgot to
mention it, but a cloud which
has no part of it at a
temperature below freezing is
often called a warm cloud.
Well, that's not going
to work for silver
iodide cloud seeding.
You need to have supercooled
water in that
cloud for it to work.
It would have to be something
like this.
In that case, you inject the
silver iodide either from the
ground, or from an aircraft,
or from a rocket.
And you hope that you're
putting in just
enough and not too much.
What happens if you
put in too much?
If you put in too much, you're
going to freeze a large number
of cloud droplets.
And they're all going to be
competing for the same water.
So they're not going to grow.
So on average, you have to
freeze about one in a million.
To make this most effective, you
want to freeze about one
in a million of the
cloud droplets.
Then you would get a million
cloud droplets contributing to
one snowflake.
That would be ideal.
This is a bit of a dirty subject
though because there
is a lot of people doing this,
a lot of cash being handed
around and hopeful farmers
paying for this.
But the scientific, and I
should say statistical
evidence that this works
is not so clear.
And the National Science
Foundation has stopped funding
most research on cloud seeding
because the people who were
doing that work were not
maintaining the highest
standards of statistical
verification of their work.
The problem is if you seed a
cloud, and it rains, how do
you know that it wasn't
going to rain anyway?
That's the big problem.
So in order to do this properly,
you would have to
seed perhaps 1,000 clouds,
half with a placebo.
You do a blind test. Because if
you allow the people that
are doing the seeding to pick
the clouds they're going to
seed, they may pick the
clouds that look most
likely to rain anyway.
So you really need to maintain
very high standards of
statistical verification
on this.
And in the early days,
this was not done.
The field is beginning to come
back now with a little higher
level of statistical
verification and beginning to
become acceptable again
scientifically.
But as I say, there's still
a big industry.
For example, every year, seeding
all along the Sierra
Nevada range in California is
done, and the claim is that
has been increasing the
snow pack every year.
Even in the tropics, there is an
industry claiming that they
can seed warm clouds.
This is even less likely
to be the case.
First of all, silver iodide
wouldn't work.
You'd have to have something
else-- in this case, you'd be
trying to enhance this mechanism
because it's the
only one that could work
for a warm cloud.
And the way you would do that
would be perhaps to drop some
kind of hydroscopic nuclei into
it, like a salt particle,
for example.
Salt likes to pick up water.
And if you could drop some salt
crystals in there, you
might be able to produce some
droplets that are a little bit
larger than the others.
And that would enhance the
collision-coalescence mechanism.
But as I say, this is even
less further along as a
scientific development than is
the seeding of cold clouds.
Question?
Yes?
STUDENT: Are there any
environmental concerns,
putting silver iodide in-- ?
PROFESSOR: The question is
are there are
environmental concerns?
Well, yeah, that's been
discussed widely.
Silver iodide, I think the
saving thing here is that you
don't want to put very
much in anyway.
So you only put a small amount
of silver iodide in.
And there has been though--
people have been able to find
the remains of this in the
environment.
But as far as I know, silver
iodide is not a particularly
dangerous compound.
But do a check for yourself.
Just Google silver iodide.
AgI is the chemical formula.
And see if it has any-- as far
as I know, except for recent
literature, I haven't followed,
there been no
environmental problems
detected for that.
But that's a good question
worth looking into.
Other questions on rain?
Yes?
STUDENT: I guess the
semi-legendary old belief that
if you fired canons it would
cause rain, does that have any
basis in reality?
PROFESSOR: Not that I know of.
I've heard that as well.
Firing cannons was hoping
to trigger this.
I don't think there's
any scientific
evidence that that works.
Anything else on this?
OK.
So what are we looking for
in terms of climatology?
A given region of the Earth will
have certain water vapor
sources, nearby bodies
of water.
It will have certain
characteristics that might
make air rise.
If you get the right conditions,
you might get
precipitation.
But this will vary from place
to place around the world.
We'll talk about the global
climatology of rainfall in
just a few days.
But there are some regions
of the Earth
where it never rains.
Why would that be?
Why would there be a place on
Earth where it never rains?
Anybody have an idea?
STUDENT: If it's like right
after a big mountain range,
that like a cloud would
have to lose all its
water to pass over?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that would
be possible.
But I think, even in that
scenario, I would offer a
slightly different
explanation.
And that is if you have a
mountain range, and the wind
is always from one side towards
the other, you'd have
rising motion on one side
which would give you
precipitation, but then
always sinking motion
on the other side.
So even if you hadn't rained
out all the water, once you
start the air descending,
then you see you
clear out the clouds.
So I would like to take that
option because I think it's
more universal.
Wherever you have on the globe,
a place where the air
is usually descending for
whatever reason, you're
unlikely to form either clouds
or precipitation.
Wherever you have regions
where the air is often
ascending, then you are much
more likely to have clouds or
precipitation.
There are people that say,
well, we could make the
deserts bloom by just adding
more water vapor.
And that will not work, because
I don't care how much
water vapor you add
to the atmosphere.
If the air is always going to be
descending, for example, in
the Sahara Desert, what makes
the Sahara Desert a desert is
that the air there is
usually descending.
Adding water vapor, that's
not going to change it.
The air is still going
to be descending.
You're not going
to make clouds.
So precipitation climatology
usually has to do with where's
the air going up and where's
the air going down.
It's complicated in many ways.
But in that sense, it's very,
very simple, rising air versus
descending air.
Now a few numbers just to
put this in your mind.
We don't know exactly what part
of the Earth gets the
absolute most rainfall.
But we suspect that there are
places on Earth that get as
much as say 10 meters
of rain per year.
I did a project in the Caribbean
last spring.
And at the top of a mountainous
island down there,
we had a rain gauge installed
for several years.
And at that point, we got six
meters of rainfall per year,
which is a lot.
Here in New haven, the average
annual rainfall is about 1.5
meters, about that much rain
per year on average.
In order to do rain-fed
agriculture, not irrigated
agriculture, but rain-fed
agriculture, you need about 20
centimeters of rain per year,
about that much rain per year.
This will give you some idea
what kind of numbers we are
looking for when we try to
understand rainfall around the
globe, 20 centimeters about
what you need to do.
And it's marginal.
But that will allow you to do
a little bit of rain-fed
agriculture.
Questions on this?
OK.
We have just about enough time
for me to mention the other
side of this, and that
is evaporation.
If we now understand what makes
it rain, then we have to
understand how that water gets
back into the atmosphere to
balance the water budget of the
atmosphere, so just a word
about evaporation.
For the most part, the rate of
evaporation, well, it may
depend on many things, like wind
speed over the surface
and the humidity of the air.
But the most important thing
it depends on is the
availability of heat.
If you don't have enough heat
available, you're not going to
be able to evaporate water.
Why is that?
Because remember, the latent
heat of condensation
evaporation is a very large
number, more than a million
joules of heat required
to evaporate
every kilogram of water.
So if you tried to evaporate
water without plenty of heat
available, you'll quickly cool
that water down and the
evaporation will cease.
In order to sustain hour after
hour evaporation, you've got
to have a supply of heat.
And that largely depends
on the air temperature.
So of all the possible controls
that might be going
on with evaporation, air
temperature is the most
important one.
I've put together a crude
empirical formula.
I wouldn't use this if I had
to do a very accurate
calculation.
But I use it all the time for
quick back-of-the-envelope
estimates of how much
evaporation
is likely to occur.
And here's the formula.
Now PET means potential
evapotranspiration.
Evapotranspiration combines
the words evaporation and
transpiration, which means it
includes both evaporation from
water surfaces and
transpiration from leaf
surfaces.
Leaves are very effective
evaporating agents.
Trees bring water up from the
ground in their roots.
And then in the leaves, there
are small pores that allow
that water to escape into
the atmosphere.
So we combine that, evaporation
and transpiration,
and call it ET.
But now this is the potential
evapotranspiration.
Because I want to remind you
that if you don't have water
there to begin with, you
can't evaporate it.
So potential evapotranspiration
is the
evaporation rate you will have
if there is water present.
If there is water present.
And here's the formula, 5.7, a
constant that I've developed,
times the temperature expressed
in degrees Celsius,
if you want millimeters
per month.
If you want millimeters per day,
just divide that by 30.
And you get 0.17 millimeters
per day per degrees Celsius
multiplied by the temperature
in Celsius.
Let's do a quick example.
Let's say the average
temperature today is going to
be 20 degrees Celsius.
So 20 degrees Celsius there,
multiply that times 20.
And what do you get?
You get about four millimeters
of evaporation.
So my prediction today if the
average temperature is 20
degrees, that you would get
four millimeters of
evaporation from the
New Haven region.
Part of it would come from
puddles of water, part of it
would come from leaves,
part from grass.
But on average with a
temperature of 20 degrees
Celsius, you get about two
millimeters of evaporated
water, water going from liquid
into vapor during the day.
Are there any questions
on that?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Does that considered
the relative humidity of--
PROFESSOR: No.
So I've neglected a few effects
that are rather
important as well, such
as relative humidity.
If the air is drier, it'll
evaporate more quickly.
If the wind is blowing strong,
it'll evaporate more quickly.
So I have neglected that.
And you should make a note about
that, that this is not a
very accurate method for doing
it because it's ignored such
factors as the one that
was just mentioned.
But I often use it-- when I know
what the precipitation is
for some part of the world, and
I want to know if that's
matched by evaporation, I'll do
a quick estimate of this,
compare with what I
know about that.
And that's usually the most
important aridity index.
To know how much it rains
is not sufficient.
To know whether a climate is
going to be wet or dry, you
need to compare the
precipitation with the
potential evapotranspiration.
It's only in that comparison
that you get
a reasonable number.
For example, in the high
latitudes, up in Northern
Canada, for example, it
rains very little.
But yet, it's a very
wet climate--
mud, puddles of water
everywhere.
How can that be if it
rains so little?
Well, it's cold, and
therefore, the
evaporation is even less.
So a wet climate is one that
has more precipitation than
evapotranspiration.
A dry climate is the
reverse of that.
You always must be comparing the
two when you're deciding
whether a climate
is wet or dry.
We're out of time.
We'll continue this
on Wednesday.